welcome back to New rockstars I'm Eric
Boss and Loki season 2 reveals the TVA
to be much darker than we thought with
torture devices and a process of killing
Beyond pruning someone out of time so
that they can get fed to a smoke monster
and this video is sponsored by
Squarespace the all-in-one platform that
makes launching your website of Breeze
but what exactly is the difference
between pruning and death in the TVA of
the Marvel Universe yeah this video is
essentially asking what happens when we
die and hoping for a clear answer from
hell I I'm going to do my best to
explain Marvel's distinction between
death and pruning and how it all comes
down to the concept of the temporal Aura
and by the way I am wearing one of our
Loki inspired shirt designs available
from nerd riot. shop really the best way
to support what we're doing here to best
cover this season of Loki season 2 okay
up through loky season 1 episode 4 we
had assumed that there was one way in
and one way out of the TVA to get in the
TVA Hunters open a Time door and
physically drag you into the TVA and
then to get out to like permanently get
out they prune you out of existence but
when Loki got pruned in episode 4 he
woke up in the void a junkyard filled
with other pruned objects and people the
void is where Mobius ended up when he
was pruned and where Sylvia ended up
when she pruned herself the idea was the
void is a kind of temporary limbo where
you would be found by elith and promptly
consumed and at that point you're really
gone forever passed on to whatever
afterlife Marvel Studios is going with
that month because so far we've seen
Valhalla the ancestral plane the duat of
moonnight that orange colored Way
Station that Thanos visited the whole
limbo realm that rocket entered in
Guardians volume 3 though we do have to
say in moonnight towett explained that
the datat in the wakandan ancestral
plane were part of the same concept but
we just don't know if any of that is
going to apply to this title or any
future Marvel title what we do know is
that there seems to be a difference
between pruning and killing and that
directly dying is now absolutely a
possibility in the TVA a terrifying one
back in season 1 episode 4 when Mobius
inquired about the status of C20 that
was the hunter that Sylvia had kidnapped
and Enchanted movius learned that her
status was marked as d ceased and at the
time we took that to mean that she was
just pruned but this was before the void
episode so we weren't really sure if
that meant executed or banished to the
void and fed to elath and at that point
a death by Exile but now in season 2
episode 2 of Loki B15 doesn't really
mince words about what happened to C20
Ren Slayer killed C20 attempted to kill
Mobius threw me in time jail and tried
to take over the TVA by killed C20 and
attempted to kill Mobius it sounds like
B15 is stain Rin Slayer pruned C20 as
well but that C20 did not survive elith
season 2 episode 2 also established a
horrifying new feature of the TVA the
time Cube activated by a crank operated
shopback looking thing the time Cube
forms around an inmate and condenses at
the push of a button crushing whatever
is inside I pointed out in the breakdown
how the floor beneath them is grated as
if to allow any gooey viscera to seep
down into a drain so this plus
spaghettification that OB described are
processes that lead directly to death in
the TVA in season 2 episode 1 OB
described Des cribe what this process
will feel like and then your suit will
age away you will age away and you'll
get very old and all your skin will get
peled away and you will die yeah he says
die so that is what is kind of happening
to Mobius suit when he goes close to the
core the radiation is actually just
rapidly aging his suit through the
hundreds of years of wear and tear that
it would go through in its normal
existence the reason the duct tape
doesn't Fray is that duct tape is what a
man kind's greatest inventions and
doesn't degrade as easily so OB is
saying that Mobius will get very old and
lose his skin and die so then what is
pruning and how is that different well
pruning is the process of extracting
one's temporal Aura from time and
displacing it somewhere else so the
temporal Aura is a term that has
returned this season of Loki it sort of
refers to a person's time Soul a kind of
cosmic fingerprint that locates you
wherever and whenever you are in the
time stream and proves your identity
like in season 2 episode 2 OB learns
that they need the temporal Aura of he
who remains to access the temporal Loom
since he who remains is dead and we know
the season is going to take us to the
Kang variant of Victor timely presumably
temporal auras are shared by variants or
at least they're similar enough to
register in these TVA scans now if you
have an online business you're going to
want to make sure everything looks and
works smoothly before the holidays roll
around which means right now is the
right time to check out Squarespace
Squarespace is an all-in-one platform
that provides you with everything you
need to do whatever you need with your
website Squarespace has templates and
designs for pretty much everything so
when you're making your very first
website using Squarespace makes it super
easy to customize your look update
content and add features to fit your
unique needs for instance Squarespace
makes it easy to sell merch you can
design your products then save time and
money by letting Squarespace handle
production inventory and shipping and if
you're selling any other kind of
physical Goods digital Goods or even a
service Squarespace makes it easy to
build your storefront and grow your
business to check it out for yourself
head to squarespace.com for a free trial
and when you're ready to launch go to
squarespace.com neww rockstars to save
10% off your first purchase of a website
or a domain so when Loki was first
processed through the TVA one of the
first things they do is scan one's
temporal Aura please confirm to your
knowledge that you are not a fully
robotic being we're born an organic
creature and do in fact possess what
many cultures would call a soul what if
I was a robot and I didn't know it the
machine would melt you from the inside
out what's that your temporal Aura so
this temporal Aura is just another way
of measuring what human cultures
consider to be a soul and the only
reason human cultures have ever
identified the concept of the soul is
because the human beings are trying to
justify what the concept of the
afterlife is so for a culture to care
about the soul is a culture to care
about the afterlife and to have a
religion a spiritual belief system but
to call it the temporal Aura is really
the TVA trying to measure it through the
dimension of time it's a metaphysical
concept that views human beings through
a filtered lens of time and this
printout that Loki sees is not listed in
numbers or words or data of any kind but
rather just kind of a gradient of
swirling colors on developing film
honestly it kind of looks like the
swirling colors formed when someone gets
pruned as long as those colors are still
there the temporal Aura is is still
intact and the soul is still with us and
no final death has occurred so long as
something has a soul it means that it
registered somewhere at some time in the
time stream it was sentient life that
existed and that temporal Aura can be
extracted and relocated and that's
really all that pruning does but when a
liath consumes you that temporal Aura is
extinguished and you truly are erased
from all time at that point he remain
said elath was formed by the cracks in
reality so therefore elith is made up of
non-existence essentially when he
consumes you he converts your matter
into antimatter and there's really no
coming back from that so at the end of
season 2 episode 2 when B15 and the
others witnessed General Doc's
successful bombing in the sacred
timeline branches what is really
happening to all those billions of
people and by the way in the breakdown I
did the math and based on the number of
branched Earths that would get pruned
the total number of pruned lives would
be closer to 2.7 trillion which is
actually 2700 billions now General doc
achieved those prunings by using temp
ads and reset charges each reset charge
prunes an entire Branch now back in
season 1 it wasn't totally clear if each
charge had a limited range like if it
merely pruned the nearby vicinity where
someone would have noticed and witnessed
the altered history and the butterfly
effect could live on from that point
like maybe it just would have pruned the
renfair in ashkash Wisconsin rather than
all of Earth in 1985 or just that part
of the GOI desert in 2012 but here based
on b15s horrified reaction in season 2
episode 2 everyone who was on Earth in
that particular Branch timeline had lost
their lives because it had already
passed the red zone at that point an
entire New World had spawned from each
branch and if all of those Souls were
pruned and relocated to the void where
they'd be devoured by elith yeah it's
just kind of an awful thing to think
about hundreds of millions of families
holding each other screaming as they
were enveloped by purple smoke so
applying this to the afterlives we've
seen elsewhere in the MCU like when
Steven Grant and Mark Spectre go to the
duat are there temporal auras or maybe
their shared one temporal Aura still
intact at that point Point does Jane
Foster still have a temporal Aura did
the dusted in Avengers Infinity war and
Avengers ingame have temporal auras just
kind of interesting to think about like
seeing the MCU through these time
fingerprints gives us a whole new
understanding of existence versus
non-existence like if someone has ever
existed so long as someone remembers
them then they are still with us now
it's October and I'm reminded of the
understanding of the afterlife explored
by those who celebrate deados muos and
honor their loved ones with ofendas
actually now would be a good time to
re-watch Pixar's Coco by the way
especially if you need a good cry or if
you have loved ones in your life who are
going through things like memory loss
it's really hard I think one of the most
profound things that Koko does is that
they touch on this idea that we die
twice once when our body dies and then
again when the last person who remembers
US thinks about us for the last time
which is really why ancestral afras are
so important so what happens when we die
well in the MCU in Loki unless you
spaghettify or you get crushed in a Time
Cube your soul really just transfers
somewhere else but the aura the aura
remains and the AA I was really the best
thing about them right yeah I got kind
of real there for a second there but you
know what I think that's what good shows
do they bring us together and they take
us to these places and I hope you are
getting as much out of Loki season 2 as
I am and I really really really
appreciate you watching our videos
myself our writers especially our
editors work so hard on these and if you
could just take some time to like this
video to subscribe to check out some of
our other content across our Network or
if you can support us by grabbing a
shirt at nerd r. shop we would just
really really appreciate it you can
follow me at eaos and I'll see you next
time thanks for watching bye everybody
[Music]
see